Tyler T Foley and just for brat so heer's line
takes on more of an offensive footing and here's
heer right away trying to fuddle it for Brad it's
knocked away from him Kaden gouy Monahan feeds
Baron he sweeps in down low Baron on the wrap
around dos made the safe oh there was a lot of
net there Baron just couldn't Square it up toward
goal trying to get it ahead Teo Meyer Meyer is
in on side he gets the puck nit is in front Meer
sends it all the way through it was deflect Marino
shot deflected by Meer and on monimbo good match
up there and you know Nico does just listening to
him in the press and and in with the media he's
got a lot of confidence right now and I like a
goalen or any player here's Luke Hughes sending it
down low Bastion retrieves Luke gets it back Colin
Miller has all kinds of space he snaps it on Save
monmo rebound Bastion hacks out it just wide your
lovsky last night it's the first time Nemesis
D's been in person to see him here in the NHL
as toley shot is denied by monmo he's a pointed
game type of player and we know the responsible
Here Comes team o he's in mball makes the save
oh boy what a great pass a good play watch this
little saucer pass from merer Cuts right in and
bury it but good chance mono equal to the task
makes a great save the encouraging thing he looks
like he's skating very well here out of the shoot
in his first game after missing six that was what
was slow to come along when he came back from his
lower body injury earlier in the year right off
the bat slop kovsky receives a bouncing Puck and
scores so the devils are denied on one end and
your ice love kovsky scores his sixth of the
year on the other big stop on the quick wrist shot
and right here Devils you know Mercer right there
didn't realize caufield's right in his back pocket
and he ends up batting this out of midair look at
this play by Coffield that's it's a pretty sharp
play and it bounced to Sosi perfectly one end we
see so often there's a response but heck of a
play by Cole Coffield as he passes that puck
out of midair as he turns his blade over Bill
and daon Mercer the reverse from niiko do the
golender Mercer didn't see Coffield coming there
so it kind of caught him by surprise a little
bit fantastic play by Coffield sets up slovsky's
sixth of the season and the 10th of his NHL career
now Joshua W is in DOS makes the save after the
Speedy W Max Wilman takes the puck away he slides
it through the goal mouth here's Luke Hughes from
the wall deflect it up and mon Timbo makes another
save his seventh already I don't know what we
talked about the energy right switch sard down
low tapped on and do makes a good save on Suzuki
better and better as he gets a little bit deeper
into his second year in the NHL I I agree with
you jury's still out but maybe got to give it
a lot more time and he's got the only goal in this
one intermission number two here's just Baron play
one behind Joshua was centers Mahan in front dos
forced to make a big save Dev was getting a little
careless around their goal tender brat comes back
the other way and couldn't get it on monmo good
recovery at the End by Jordan Harris the third
pair defenseman for the Canadians and again do
has been sharp Devils have had some chances mono
has been really good in Montreal's net but they've
got a tighten up around their net and that means
more guys in the middle of the ice Evans flutters
one to the front it trickles to Dos he got a left
pad to it here's Alexander Holtz 10 goals on the
year Holtz takes it left of the circle back for
Nemitz again Holz one time blast monmo makes the
save final minute of the period final 8 seconds
on the power play all the Glides for nitz again
nit shoots bouncing puff mono covers It Up play by
Suzuki under pressure from heer but Hughes keeps
it in at the Blue Line Marino sends it on goal
and M Timbo Smothers that one 20.1 to play in the
frame back after missing six with a midbody injury
brat sends it down low to fley looking he holds he
centers he shoots no rebound is denied by monimbo
sure was going to have a slam dunk here there's
the patient I'm talking about from tole gets
it to charl mono gets that left pad out that
little drag was enough to create a lane for
him he's got it again L Hughes up top moves
it Meer one timer and a save monmo you open up a
lane a little bit with a couple of passes but it
seems they're deferring to to that outside shot
yeah I mean there are a lot of areas where you
miss douge Hamilton on the point on the power
play for a shooting threat could have made it
a three-on-one but he was limping because of
that block shot that created the outnumbered
situation in the first place now it's Gallagher
walking across the other and he couldn't jam it
home developing the goals here bill is 13 55 left
in the second here's Mercer in front monbo saves
him and then he takes a bump from Mercer going
after the rebound what a great chance remember
anything can happen in Jersey it's Devil's chances
there's Mercer feeds the Blue Line strubel gets it
right back strubel slides it all the way through
and Jordan Harris couldn't deflect it going back
door the other way Eric Hall is in behind halling
DS he shoots in a save mono again it's a nice feed
from Meyer Stoned by Mono what a pass off the
N wall right from the devil's Z by Brat s haana
Devils have been all over the goal in this period
a lot of big chances just need the breakr now it's
a two-on-one going the other way sha Mahan is
in he cuts in front score Joshua W scores his
first career and HL goal well again after a
great chance for the Devils um Monahan I mean
watch watch this poison patience he just delays
delays knows exactly where why is and he scores
his first an easy one there as Sha Monahan this
is just terrific and by the Montreal Canadians
in L Hughes moves it to Meyer again here's heer
ice toward goal feeds the Blue Line Luke Hughes
lets it Go score Luke Hughes rifles it from
the blue line and the devil's score with two
minutes of power play action left we've talked
about Luke Hughes for me he has to shoot the
puck more and he does just that he's sure the
captain stays patient Luke Hughes head up all
the way he's got a terrific wrist shot teamer
Pro provides a screen this ends up going off
J left skate outside of it Meer and heer
no stick for Stevens and he couldn't quite
get there but n has to come back out to the
neutral zone NE shoots it on and MBO blockers
it away remember Luke Hughes missed morning
skate this morning he is fighting through
his sickness but he has the Devils back in it
here's h w he scores Alexander htz ties the
game two goals in one 38 to open the period both
on the power play abolute missile by Alexander
Holtz and initially he does a good job to keep
a bouncing Puck alive and in the offensive zone
then he receives a pass and he just lets it Fly he
gets all of it right in his wheelhouse the onetime
scored a late winner on Monday when Montreal beat
Colorado armia got it again feeds it comes across
Jordan Harris with cranks it rebound score it
trickled away from Ni do and Cole Coffield put
it in with 431 to go well there was a good save
initially on the blast but the defenseman right
here the Devils this is where you've got to win
that puck battle that leaves Harris W wide open
and then Marino gets on the wrong side of of
Cofield but he just uses that strength inside
position right there great play by Monahan here
to he moved the puck 7 Seconds now six nit with
five is going backwards with three he sends it
forward that is by him and there is the buzzer